n
[Música]
después de meses de incertidumbre de un
break si duro y al borde de la fecha
límite la unión europea y el reino
unido- lograron cerrar un acuerdo
histórico sobre su relación tras el
divorcio les contamos cómo se regirán
las relaciones entre bruselas y londres
a partir del primero de enero la
vacunación masiva ya convencional en
américa latina'
méxico se convirtió en el primer país de
la región en vacunar al aplicar su
primera inyección a una enfermera
seguido de chile que también comenzó a
aplicar al personal sanitario y costa
rica analizamos con una médica
epidemióloga del cepi
feliz navidad a esta hora más de la
mitad del planeta ya celebró la noche
buena en condiciones atípicas
mientras en el continente americano las
familias se preparan para una inédita
noche navideña el papá francisco
adelantó la tradicional misa de gallo
por la pandemia tenemos reporte desde
roma
hola cómo están bienvenidos a las
noticias aquí en france 24 hoy que es 24
de diciembre y empezamos con el break
city y es que después de meses de duras
negociaciones tanto reino unido como la
unión europea lograron un pacto que
regirá sus relaciones a partir del
primero de enero de 2021 a sólo una
semana de que terminara el plazo para
que la legislación comunitaria deje de
aplicarse en territorio británico
el pacto abarca no sólo el comercio de
bienes y servicios sino también la
circulación de personas la competencia o
el transporte veamos más en este informe
de federico que barberena donde
repasamos las claves del acuerdo que
pone fin a 47 años de membresía
británica en el bloque europeo
es el fin a una relación de 47 años
reino unido y la unión europea-
definieron un histórico acuerdo
comercial y de cooperación post bread
sit el pacto prevé el libre intercambio
de bienes y servicios sin aranceles ni
cuotas aunque con más restricciones que
en la transición una salida airosa para
el reino unido que se arriesgaba a
enfrentar tarifas o luego de tres
décadas en el mercado único el acuerdo
también modifica las reglas en un área
clave la pesca con esta normativa la
unión europea acepta un recorte del 25
por ciento de las cuotas en aguas
británicas durante cinco años y medio
estará garantizado el acceso recíproco a
las aguas pero tras ese periodo las
condiciones se definirán en
negociaciones anuales
sin semestre por primera vez desde 1973
seremos un estado costero independiente
con control total de nuestras aguas con
la participación del reino unido de la
pesca aumentando sustancialmente de
aproximadamente la mitad actual además
de cerca de dos tercios en cinco años y
medio en five mahaffey the strain
el texto contempla que londres y
bruselas mantengan un campo de juego
nivelado con los mismos estándares de
competencia y protección al medio
ambiente
desde el primero de enero de 2021
existirán controles aduaneros en las
fronteras y los ciudadanos no podrán
circular libremente instalarse y
trabajar o estudiar para estancias
superiores a 90 días se deberán
solicitar los visados correspondientes
también se acabará el reconocimiento
mutuo de las calificaciones
profesionales
sé que este es un día difícil para
algunos y a nuestros amigos en
reinounido quiero decirles despedirse es
un dolor tan dulce arking es sachs sweet
una despedida que tampoco será
definitiva a la cooperación esperada
entre las partes se agrega que el
acuerdo incluye periodos de transición y
cláusulas de revisión lo que vaticinan
nuevas negociaciones en el futuro
una parte de américa latina comenzó hoy
sus jornadas de vacunación contra el
hobbit 19méxico chile y costa rica
recibieron sus primeras dosis de las
farmacéuticas facer y by un tec y
empezaron a inmunizar al personal de
salud y adultos mayores argentina por su
parte empezará su jornada la próxima
semana con la vacuna rusa y sputnik
mientras que otros países como colombia
y ecuador esperan vacunar a su población
para principios de 2021 es por ello que
enlazamos con la médica epidemiólogo
patricia garcía integrante del comité
asesor de la coalición para las
innovaciones en la preparación ante las
epidemias la sepi doctora gracias por
esta comunicación vemos que los países
más pobres se están quedando atrás en la
carrera de la vacunación la sepi de la
cual usted hace parte codirige el kóvacs
que fue creado para evitar que esto
pasara cuando van a recibir la vacuna a
los países que no hicieron compras
adicionales y sólo se confiaron en este
mecanismo de lado de meses
como estas hablan justamente kóvacs la
idea de kóvacs y tener esta plataforma o
esta coalición de países es justamente
poder ayudar a los países que a poder
negociar mejor la posibilidad de tener
vacunas y las negocios participan más de
190 países y lo que se espera es que en
el primer trimestre del próximo año
todos los países un 190 los que son
parte de esta coalición deberán estar
recibiendo las primeras dosis de vacunas
que van a incluir vacunas como para ser
modernas y otras más que están dentro de
las negociaciones
entonces si bien es cierto hay un
retraso esperemos que ese retraso no sea
tan grande como más va a permitir que
los países reciban al menos el 20 por
ciento de las vacunas que necesitan para
toda su población y la idea es que como
está pasando en todos los países se
comiencen vacunando a las poblaciones
que se consideran más críticas personal
de salud y la población vulnerable en
algunos países también se va a incluir
como pasa en el caso del perú en el que
estoy yo
probablemente el personal policial que
va a ayudar a poder organizar todo el
tema de las vacunaciones doctor están
preparados los gobiernos
latinoamericanos para los grandes
desafíos que implican las fórmulas
contra el cob y 19 retos cómo mantener
las vacunas a ciertas temperaturas
algunas extremas la necesidad de que se
apliquen dos dosis por persona para su
efectividad o el conseguir millones de
jeringas y agujas de inyección
bueno vamos a comenzar por la parte de
atrás el conseguir todos los insumos que
se requieren esto es una cosa que los
países todos los países latinoamericanos
han debido estar trabajando durante todo
este periodo mientras se esperaba
evaluar la efectividad para decidir con
cuál de las vacunas se hacían y lo que
se espera y los países han estado
trabajando de manera independiente
algunos también trabajando con la
organización por 'the para medicar en la
salud para poder tener todos esos
insumos esperemos que lo tengan eso es
lo primero lo segundo el definitivamente
es un gran reto vacunas como la de facer
esta vacuna requiere ultra freezer
refrigeración de -70 y tengo que decirte
que en muchos de nuestros países eso no
es posible y va a ser sumamente
complicado probablemente esa es la razón
por la cual algunos países incluyendo ha
habido muchas dificultades en nuestro
caso en el caso del perú porque va a ser
sumamente complicado manejar vacunas
como esas pero tenemos otras vacunas
inclusive por ejemplo la vacuna moderna
ya no requiere ese ultra free se resiste
requiere menos 20 es más fácil y van a
venir otras vacunas y hay otras vacunas
que
se espera que se mantengan que mantener
solamente en las temperaturas que son
las regulares de cadena de frío para las
cuales estamos acostumbrados
definitivamente la vacuna para ser con
menos 70 no es la más adecuada excepto
para algunas zonas urbanas pero para
poder lograr accesibilidad esa esa no va
a ser el mejor camino para mí para
latinoamérica ni probablemente para
áfrica e incluso en algunos lugares en
otros países como eeuu ellos van a tener
dificultades con esta vacuna para
mantener la cadena de frío doctora
patricia garcía muchas gracias ella es
integrante del comité asesor de la
coalición para las innovaciones en la
preparación ante las epidemias y va a
unos otros temas porque hoy los
creyentes celebran una navidad una
atípica en el vaticano en la plaza de
san pedro donde cada año se congregan
miles de personas para escuchar la misa
de nochebuena está vacía esta nochebuena
por primera vez la misa de medianoche
fue adelantada para que todos pudieran
volver a sus hogares antes del toque de
queda por la pandemia y también hay otra
novedad la bendición del papá francisco
urbieta
es en la basílica de san pedro y no en
la logia central sin multitudes
escuchamos a nuestra corresponsal ante
elementos
[Música]
se trata de una vigilia de navidad sin
precedentes en la historia reciente del
cristianismo este año a causa del
coronavirus la tradicional misa de gallo
ha sido adelantada años atrás esta misa
se llevaba a cabo a medianoche pero este
jueves el papá francisco dio inicio a
esta celebración a las siete y treinta
de la noche hora de roma para permitir a
las personas presentes lograr regresar a
sus hogares antes del inicio del toque
de queda impuesto por el gobierno
italiano a partir de las 10 de la noche
hora de roma la misa el papá francisco
se llevó a cabo en la basílica de san
pedro en el vaticano que pueden ver aquí
detrás mío estuvo enmarcada por un
estricto protocolo de seguridad
sanitaria poquísimas personas estuvieron
presentes son un centenar de personas
pudieron entrar mientras que el año
pasado más de siete mil fieles católicos
acompañaron al papá francisco durante
esta ocasión este jueves durante su
homilía el papá francisco evocó el
sentido profundo de lo que es la navidad
el contexto de extrema
humildad en el cual se dio el nacimiento
del niño jesús y exhortó a los fieles
católicos a vivir estas fiestas lejos
del espíritu del consumismo y tratando
de ayudar a los más necesitados mucha
felicidad a todos ustedes feliz navidad
disfrute de su noche siga con nosotros
aquí en france 24
[Música]